if I was telling a kid right now I'd say
brother unless brother sister unless
there's a super serious thing you can
get a degree in that you can exchange
for your green rectangles
don't go yeah cuz all these P half the
people going in right now are getting
degrees that mean nothing I'm Dave Rubin
and this is the Rubin report reminder
everybody subscribed to Rubin report
calm if you want to get all our videos
early and totally add free and more
importantly joining me today is a
stand-up comic and host of Dennis Miller
plus one on the RT network as well as
the Dennis Miller option podcast Dennis
Miller I've already said your name three
times
what's up rubes welcome to the Rubin
report beautiful pad here man I'm trying
to read you can tell a man by his books
and how am i doing his tchotchkes I see
they were a Karlin fan which I find in
your little steven pinker NBA I think
your detractors would say this indicates
you're moving rightward towards John
Birch participation party have the math
centered out an odd confluence between
South America and or the globe I should
say South America and Africa where it's
split up and now I have a theory it
looks like they were together at one
point yeah they've split apart and
obviously the west coast of Africa with
Ivory Coast Liberia is the most
contentious place in the planet and I
think that's a sudden hard drive tremble
from way back when where a guy went out
into his yard and Liberia once and said
honey what's this crack and then two
weeks later I've often wondered how
Pangaea split I'm giving you a little
something of everything here cuz we got
lefties we got righties look I got an
American flag in the control I love over
there I always love to have a map in my
studio to feel situated yeah so you got
two shows you've done a bajillion things
I said to you right before I'm not even
gonna use notes I try not to really look
at my notes when I talk to most guests
anyway I thought I just sit down and see
what happens you kind of just need to be
wound up and then you go right
well you know what but I I tell you as I
get older I need to be
that would like to go less I'm just
listen it's a contentious now I was at
more of a I don't want to use the entire
term firebrand but I was more willing to
engage lock antlers when I was young I
don't think people are gonna change
their minds anymore I don't want to be
the carnival barker on some freak show
people or split we'll find out where we
go which way at each election in between
it's gonna be contentious at age 66 I
don't want to wake up every day and
fight with people that's stuff they're
not gonna change their mind on anyway
so when I get going I like to put on a
good show you know your your Spanky and
our gang let's put on a show but I don't
need the I don't need to get going as
much anymore so you're like an evolved
political satirist or something I just I
used to dig the game when you could
budge somebody an angstrom I didn't need
them to come over I never thought did
you gotta talk to somebody and they were
gonna desert their core beliefs and come
over your way but they at least you
could see the mulling I think Mullings
gone I could see Moon's gone it's just
now people nobody's everybody's dug in
and I'm mad I'm trying over here no I
appreciate but like I said I don't know
you're in your 40s right I would
probably fought the flop more then but
I'm telling you why you seem like that
just the time we talked before and you
seem like smart enough got that
somewhere down the road I can't see you
fighting it into the barn seem to be
alone you know beautiful family in the
picture out here got a great place
you're kicking ass and taking names
career wise yeah you should do it now
but at some point the the harvest is
gonna do I'm into getting up and reading
taking a hike having a good meal
appreciating the fact I married the most
beautiful witty charming girl I ever met
during my son's watching some baseball
and then reading as I fall out to sleep
is that a tough thing though for a comic
I have to face no for me what do you
think for most comics that's like you
almost like a fear that you fear the
okayness cuz you won't have the fuel
it's a convenient it's a job yeah I was
never very I don't be a show business is
some sword from the stone moment where
you're annoying
good job I got Pittsburgh and my job
what I was good at was I would think
jokes up and then I tried to give those
jokes to somebody else to do and then I
found I didn't have the ego for that
once I saw somebody do a joke I thought
up on The Tonight Show and Carson
laughing I thought I'm not built for
this I better become the unlikely
conduit but I've never thought of myself
as the Silver Surfer he competed yeah
and so no I don't you know I don't have
any moment pangs or anything oh I wish I
was in the frame it never was like that
when I was in the frame were you always
political because I think I should get
that job on SNL you have to become
political yeah so you weren't political
before I used to be a prop comic I
remember working with the like you know
I was never quite carat opium but I got
an actual word I think that's probably
in the dictionary now that's depressing
I I did props when I first started
because I thought that visually that way
but then I remember I couldn't fit the
props in the overhead I had slight props
and then I thought you know I'm not
gonna wait a half an hour at a for some
inflatable seat I could put on my head
and say a last 4:30
I ditched that on that started writing
jokes like I said stoled a couple of
other comedians saw them do them and
score with them and thought I've got to
be the guy so I like I said it's very I
didn't have a whoosh-whoosh thing about
stand-up I remember thinking okay this
is a good career kind of a decision so
when you get the Weekend Update
situation in the SNL situation then it's
sort of like it was political what what
year did you start an SNL somewhere new
eighties so where some of these wasn't
me no I'm not doing this vibrantly yeah
just I remember I was maybe like 89 or
something cuz I'm trying to remember cuz
you on SNL that that class was like my
formative comedy year class so I was
like twelve thirteen around then and I
think I think maybe like 89 or something
like that well some people think of
themselves as comedic visionaries I
choose to think of ourselves as assuring
kids through puberty
we were they if you were 12 yeah yeah
that's all we were there was a 15
minutes off
jerkin oh yeah but you guys didn't see I
made it out okay but I remember I was in
Baltimore and I had auditioned for SNL
maybe a month before and then I remember
they picked the cast USA Today had
picture of them I wasn't in and I was
still in Baltimore and I was so tough at
that point because on your way up you
have to be tough I stand up with New
York 12 years I was a gladiator and I
remember seeing that picture I didn't
have a crestfallen thing I think I came
close to that all right keep going then
I was up doing Letterman and somebody
came into the Letterman dressing room
and said listen Lauren Michaels wants to
see you on 8:00 or no 17 where his
office was and I said Jesus I knew
something he's not calling me down to
revisit me to tell me why it yeah you're
really not getting it but I'm thinking
maybe I get a shot on it as a comedian
or something like Stephen right what
come on Sam once it off so I went down I
knew it was gonna be something good but
then I walked in I remember it's one of
those moments that stick in your head
Lawrence it's that the other thing he's
got one of those green dome two glasses
a lights on his desk you know that gives
it that Arthur Conan Doyle feel he's got
the quarter glasses on reading scripts
or something and over his shoulders the
Empire State Building and I remember it
being like red white and blue it wasn't
for the July or anything but he looks up
and he goes hey Dennis Miller I got hey
Loren he says I would you like to do
weekend update' and I said I'd like that
a lot well I'll see you tomorrow around
11:00 I said all right sir
I walked out and I remember thinking I'm
not a big drinker but I remember saying
I'm gonna go get four fingers of
something brown rocks and knock that's
dad because this is pivotal and that was
magical I don't want to act like I'm
sitting over a beauty I'm talking about
stand-up I was kind of step by step
Maginot Line move it six inches fall
back four move it four but when that
happened I remember thinking all right
take some mental Polaroids here don't be
blase about this because that's its own
defense mechanism this is a big deal
Chevy Chase did this you're gonna do it
now enjoy it until you either become a
success or get whacked so I did enjoy it
a long way I took all those moments and
you know the first time you sitting that
see ya count you dad I just thought all
right I might go out but I'm going out
on my shield here so even though you
weren't purely political they pegged you
for that were you is that what is that
is that what you wanted did you want to
do more I wanted any hook yeah I think
I'm not a character guy I used to try to
stay out of the SNL sketches because you
know when you're with geniuses Carvey's
comedic genius Lovitz the sketch wise a
genius Phil I mean the only guy I never
thought I'd see a guy like Danny and
Phil got in the room with him and I
always thought wow this is a serious
play Mike Myers comes in so you've got
four leads there it can kill the ball
I'm the fifth guy in a sketch I'm the
bartender saying here's your gimlet and
yet I got to be there blocking it for
three and a half hours so I used to go
around that say to writers when they
wrote me and I'd say yeah I want to be
like the D H I want to pick a rock song
they're having the weighted bat downtown
oval come out and you know hit the ball
for ten minutes and by the end you had
that right yeah it was a groovy job yeah
I used to I probably been around a dozen
sketches over the years and they were
ones where I thought oh this is good I
should stay in this because I want to
see I want to see this when I get older
I it's a wonderful life the next chapter
you know you know when something was
gonna be a big hit but by and large I
was really happy to have just Weekend
Update I'm sure you've been asked this a
million times but what do you think it
is about SNL or the ages or the
collection or the level of talent of all
the people that there's so much tragedy
around the cast members go back and
study that is there well I mean deaths
and drug use thank you some drug use
he's just Hollywood but yeah yeah John
Chris I don't know I'd like to see the
actuary tables I always hear this thing
yeah so you don't even think that
there's anything I bet a lot of healthy
people there there are a few guys so I
could have met working in a hardware
store where I'd know that had it right
all right fair enough I did figure it
I'm just saying I know something about
the pressure of live maybe I don't know
something you know all that stuff seems
contrived to me hmm you're working as a
entertainer in some way and all of a
sudden you're on the best enter
tainment vehicle for young people in the
world quite frankly no no you can spend
your days sitting in a room thinking oh
my stomach hurts I'm spill kiss I got to
go get loaded or you can just get on
with it and have a blast and it is scary
and they're there a week so it felt
horrible when you go badly that's any
gig but that whole crash and burn thing
I'm so far from that if I would have
said if somebody has said to me you know
at the end of the day this is gonna
cause you to do yourself in I said I'm
not taking the job there that magical
kingdom to me what would you have done
if not if it wasn't for comedy I would
like to maybe be shrink yeah I don't
know maybe not anymore because things
that used to interest me about people
their psychological tells now have
turned into blatant whining so I don't
think it'd be a shock for today but if
people come in and say you know wake up
but at the time I thought that might be
interesting what else do I want to do I
never even thought like that but if I
said anything that's a shrink
yeah so what do you make the way
everything's changing right now you're
doing a show on Artie mm-hm
you got a podcast everyone's got a
podcast you so you've shift around you
were on cable news for years doing your
thing with O'Reilly what do you make of
the way just the media landscape is
changing and how everyone gets
everything in a different way well tell
you what it might be my inner pragmatist
but I never even say everybody's got a
podcast I'd say there's tens of
thousands people have a podcast you
probably went over that down to a
thousand or even worth getting into the
businesses scene if you dig it you
probably get down to a hundred that
really are completely in sync with a
Peter Principle they're maxing it out
whatever talent they have you get time
to run two dozen that are killing it I
think you're in that two dozen so I
don't disparage it with that everybody
has a podcast and so everybody has a
podcast no there's a bunch of people
throwing scat up against the wall right
there's a bunch of people trying it I
would try to if I was young and I didn't
know if I was talented it's a great
thing it's like you used to jump up at
an open mic night why not do a podcast
but the simple fact is I view the
attrition rate as much the same in any
other aspect to show business
yeah I mean look at a brother you're
killing it and for me to just say
everybody's got one
no you got one well I guess yeah I'll
take the cup of it well I guess that's
math right right so the barrier to entry
is low but yeah it doesn't mean you
you've got something that's really
cooking barrier to entry should always
be low yeah anybody can jump in and try
anything they want your business is no
magic dirt I've said Magic Kingdom no
exalted higher plane
it's a showbiz it's you going out to
strangers and saying let me either
make you think cry or laugh that's all
it is at the end of the day people have
always been interested in that town
criers people you know Seventh Seal do a
garage doing the puppet shows to the the
poppers it's I don't know to me it seems
like a harddrive issue I'm sure there
was somebody sitting around the mud pit
way back when when you know in Kubrick
town crack the other and I'm sure there
was some guy trying to do a ride joinder
to the other their head rested folks I
want to tell you it's been around since
day one so I I don't know I was drawn to
it to me it should be an easy point of
entry it shouldn't be that high a bar
it's just you trying to entertain people
so what really interests you these days
like well I'm trying to write everything
PG Woodhouse or ever read I hike let's
see I'm trying to teach myself to not
you know active fames pretty it comes
out you fast and furious speaking of
Kubrick it reminds me of cure delay at
the end of thousand one where it's just
so you can't always back that's what the
whole world feels like right shoot man a
wind tunnel test and it is flying so you
can't always be lucid about it I think
that if you're on the planet for 85
years the front end of that 20 there's
guys like Eddie who beat it but usually
until 20 or anonymous and the last 10
years you've probably thirty of those
out you got a half a century if you get
any part of that where you're famous and
you're actually seated at a nice table
where strangers come up to you and say
one and I try to try to think this is
the way life should be it isn't so um
when you say what are you doing I'm
trying to what do they call it
mindfulness but that's almost falling
into it's not own cachet I'm trying to
be aware of what a great run I had and I
might be in the de new mall of that and
that's fine you know buddy you can see
when you even mention it to people where
you say I don't think it was hot as I
was I don't know if I'll ever be that
hot again you people kind of wincing oh
I see I mean it sincerely I think the
examined life is everything and I want
to examine my life I want to feel legit
here as I hopefully another 30 years get
it into the barn I want to analyze what
part of me which was a shag kid ends up
getting braggadocious not the Chavez
hits the ball hard and I think I
inhabited that plane pretty well and now
not as hot I want to inhabit that plane
just as well it's it's equally valid
yeah I love the answer I mean that's as
honest as it can get I like that I I
don't I never predicated on me riding
into the sunset with the key light on me
listen you have your moment it's harder
I don't know I know how far you into it
you know you told me you did 12 years of
stand-up so I know you got some hard
riding under your belt on a lot of
street corners of killing in now but you
know I I don't know that humans are
built to keep it up till they're all of
a sudden you're Larry Sanders doing the
show and go I don't mean her Gary yeah
yeah I know you mean Larry said there's
got back in laying in bed watching the
repeat that's know that four hours
between live show and watching it on the
East Coast feed this is know yeah yeah I
think about it sometimes even though I'm
sort of right in the thick of it right
now it's like you know when things
change or I change or family expands or
whatever it is that like will I want to
do it at this level or you deal with a
certain amount of hate or any of those
things you know it's like well you only
find out if though they won't wait I
don't want to sound like I'm on The
Bachelor yes but all I know is it was
never my trip to take it all the way in
yeah and
I'm at some point I remember thinking
it's like base camps on Everest and you
know all of a sudden you're planting the
flag you think how the hell did this
happen and then all of a sudden when
you're at six base camp and you're
boiling water with the Sherpa you think
and they say well we're not gonna let
you make the climb to my ego okay I'm
gonna get cozy yeah okay the fork I'm
fine with that they started moving down
the mine I had a big rock do you think
most people are afraid of that sort of
and that is why everyone is kind of nuts
like we're all sort of afraid of trying
to figure out what would make us
actually happy and you know so we get
obsessed with whatever the new cycle is
or whatever that answer then I turn into
the guy in the second row don't be that
guy thing I'm not a scared shitless of
anonymity as some people if I fall back
into that I'm gonna examine that in the
same way I examined being I don't know I
remember the first two years of being
famous maybe this was a tell and I when
I say famous folks where's the camera I
don't wanna sound like an [ __ ] I'm
just saying you end up famous I remember
spending two years up front not even
being able to focus on it because I
would notice it I would be too pleased
with it the pragmatic side of myself
would castigate the side that was too
pleased with it the other side would
come in and defend me against the mean
side say oh come on he's just got for me
and I'd say I'm spending 12 hours a day
figuring this out and at some point I
remember sit it's like an algebraic
equation cancel terms out it just is it
doesn't mean anything in a weird way are
you good dad
are you a good friend are you and I'm
not saying I am I as far as friends I'm
a little distant but I'm just saying
there are so many ways to shoot your
life through and when you're in it it
takes all your attention because you've
got to stay laser focused I always be
Fame like it's party oh sudden you're
outside and it's like those old Warner
Brothers cartoons where the house has
got notes coming out that bad banana de
all of a sudden you get in the door and
you like stay against the wall and it's
a Sardis character every it's like a
Last Supper of Fame and you're on you're
pressed against the wall looking at Big
O in the edge into the party and then
all of a sudden the sweet spot is
halfway into the party and then like you
have to
is there and then you realize half the
parties happening behind you and you
don't know who's gonna a to birthday in
the sauna and eventually you get through
to the other one go to the bathroom so
at some point I'm always had that in my
head from the first moment that I got it
and I so I'm not disappointed it always
seemed to have a natural shelf-life to
me yeah so I don't want to do the
greatest hits with you because I want to
I want to do sort of where you're at now
but so when you then start doing
O'Reilly and then suddenly people are
going wait a minute this is SNL Weekend
Update guys like this sort of like hip
cool live kind of suddenly you're on a
super cool or is not hip and cool I was
the same but but the optics of it now
suddenly wait when this doesn't make
sense he was on SNL and now he's on evil
Fox News I'm just saying you know
there's not my opinion this is just
little people yeah yeah yeah but did you
fear that at all or even none of it uh
interesting listen I I was on the number
one rated show on cable iving bill for
twenty years I was doing six minutes a
week it was a beautiful gig we'd got in
a road once a week whatever once a month
we'd sell ten crazy could you believe
that could he believe it we definitely
or a one plus one equals three thing
mm-hmm
because on my own I'd probably at that
point draw two I don't know what Billy
was John but probably two yeah well you
put us together in the mutton Jeff of it
it always reminded me that scene in the
Chaplin movie not saying we were Chaplin
high score Charlie puts his foot behind
his leg and kicks the guy who's working
the border guard that guy at LSI kicks
him in the butt I was doing that to
around yeah and the key moment in that
relationship was when I told Billy
you're like a big Mick beat cop Irish
meet the beat cop where you're spinning
that stick everybody scared shitless you
and I'm gonna call you Billy I got a
bill that why was a great move because
all of a sudden the the power the the
monolith is being poked fun at by the
mutton Jeff guy and it was it was cool
that's why it works again there's cuz I
could make him laugh not an unguarded
laugh periodically mm-hmm and I could
poke fun at him
I could call him Billy I could wear
shorts on his show which you know I put
my leg up do you not at all that worked
you know though are you doing a lot of
those hits from home did you have a home
situation and were you going into Fox
affiliate or something I went over this
place called the Rubin studios no I
think we did it up at Santa Barbara in
another studio we're always on split
screen
it was so funny till we started going on
the road people would say you'll bill
like we're hoping Crosby's I you know
I've met him twice
we're always on a split screen but over
the years I'll tell you what I'm
relatively ill ADIZ socially I don't
know what that is I don't want to make
it precious bill I think if you can
watch over the years are you lose I
don't cuz off camera you seem exactly
the same to me where no but there's
plenty of comics I know exactly what
you're talking about there's a lot of
comics that are weird have eye contact
stuff don't want to touch anybody and
then the second you know the camera goes
on and bam they're they're there but I
don't from the little bit we just did
our thing I didn't catch that
well I I do know that I don't go to a
lot of social events and stuff like that
when I'm working I mean a hail fellow
well met I like to say I be normal I'm
in a cat's place and but I'm not a real
social guy and he isn't either so when
you put the two of us together I was
enamored of that part over on a rally
and I sometimes didn't understand his
brusque manner and I sometimes thought
why is he beating his drum to that
degree when I'd watch him on the show
and bill if you're seeing this I know
I'm not you know I I'm telling I saw
that cat do stuff for soldiers kids
who'd been abused Haitians after storms
yeah sometimes the the in the matter the
way that doesn't matter the topical
stuff I sometimes find him equally ill
at ease as I am yeah but walking the
walk and that cat gave a lot of money to
a lot of people and I don't know whose
personal life you know people say what
about I go do you really think oh okay
so that's that's my relationship with
our ally we're now I'm gonna call him
talking about dating or whatever the
hell's going on right it's not my life
with him we went out on the road and I
saw him do a lot of good things for a
lot of people and guess what I felt no
need to know to pro
the underbelly of Bill O'Reilly or find
out what really makes him tick and he
felt no need to find out that being said
I I did seem do enough things over the
years that I find him an honorable man
yeah what do you think about the way
that we take out people these days you'd
have to make it about him specifically
but just generally you know now chris
matthews went out it's just like this
endless cascade of we're just gonna
build people up and crush them gets
worse
you know imagine like twitter during
Dickensian England it's not worse than
it's ever been that's what everyone says
every day it's worse than it's ever been
I think the way that'll turn this yeah
it might be but I think the way the
little turn is is everybody who's in the
public eye should get up to a joke a
witticism a pithy revelation and stop it
down themselves and look at the camera
and say I have something here but I'm
going to stay out because I understand
the new rules and have that happen at
nauseam for a few years and I relate to
people how crazy and our post or welling
and it's gotten as far as jokes dialogue
throwaways cruelty indeed humans are
cruel once in a while you know the fact
that that's all neutered on now I think
people should be reminded that we're
missing some of the texture of life
walking around like we're in Logan's Run
or something you know it's a I I don't
think it will change for a while because
to me it's the Lord of the Flies and
right now the uptake people have the
conch and they're the ones they're gonna
speak and therefore if I'm sitting there
and I get to a point in a joke where I
go this this puts me where I have to
talk to people who I disagree with about
how bad I am I just I stopped off at it
yeah yeah I'm not gonna say it
yeah I've tackled myself here and if
enough of that happens people are gonna
start saying hey I'm sick of this yeah
do you have a bunch that you just
wouldn't tell anymore like it's like an
old favorite that you're just like yeah
that's it's easy listen one I used to be
on network television they told you not
to swear I find that easy not to swear
when I'm in Vegas I find it easy to say
[ __ ] when I'm here I don't know what the
rules are here you'll bleep oh no we
don't believe it yeah that's a cancelled
right now I mean I don't think about it
but I am saying that
yes and not so much this point at all my
career we tell you I don't care about
that I care about having to spend time
reacting to Nimrods who quite frankly
think second-guessing is creativity it
isn't I like being with creative people
I like being with people who say things
occasional I can't believe you said that
and if I don't think it's over then and
I listen the human the human Freya's
cacophonous it's like where was it
written that you're never getting to
hear anything that falls on your you
know philia in your year and you
disagree with it I wouldn't want I don't
want to lead that life so well therefore
I'll stop myself just because I think
who needs to bring down a some white kid
telling me how I've ruined his day yeah
you know I used to do if there's some my
old stand-up tapes are right there and I
used to do a joke way back when that I
used to say the n-word and it was not to
be racist in any way it was actually a
stupid silly Transformers reference that
I was imitating a transformer and I
would say it would always get a huge
laugh huge laugh I would close with it
sometimes and then one night I was on
stage at Gotham comedy club on 24th and
the audience kind of turned on me this
is like maybe 2004 something like that
and I remember thinking I'm putting that
one away and I never did it again and
ever I never liked that feeling but I
was just like yeah this is where you
want to do a Nantucket sleigh ride with
a bit where they ride it to the bottom
yeah doesn't interest me yeah come out
there to please people I like to get
laughs and at some point if I have an
opinion and I real it's worth it
I'll push it in even if it draws ire but
there are other times I think this isn't
good enough to let this all this agita
into my life thus turbine drags tiresome
yeah you know it's so precious to me
that we sit down every day and ten times
a day somebody has to get themselves
back and spine and I remember when years
ago there was a cat who is the general
manager for the Los Angeles Dodgers al
campanis do you remember him yeah its
head before I was here but he goes on
Ted Koppel one night and he says
something that's like from another
generation racially and he's dead
he's got to go supplicate for sharpton
you know all that silly game and because
her sharpton so righteous yeah and I
remember thinking you know when Jackie
Robinson first came up and he goes to
Montreal and the Dodgers he's playing
minor league baseball and they got to
assign somebody to go out with a cat and
right you know right wing man
I think Kemp anise is right there I mean
when it came to real life yeah there
yeah and then later he says something
brutish from a dead day gone by and he's
over and I remember thinking oh this is
so tedious you know that's the smartest
thing Eric Holder ever said although I
think he backed back ended into I don't
even think he meant it the way I took it
when he said we're cowards we don't even
have chats about things anymore
racial relations indeed we don't and
guess what you want to be the first guy
in really you want to be over this
afternoon trying to make some sort of
lucid nuanced comment about interactions
between human beings of different colors
you don't want to be the first guy and
you're done it's so funny because people
think it's something new but you
remember what took out Howard Cosell 40
years oh yeah Alvin Garret yep so I
think there were two things well one was
them about his grandkids remember he oh
oh yeah right he was the guy and he
called him a little monkey or something
in 46 for ya and you know when you and
that's what he called his grandkids just
cuz he was jumping around he didn't mean
it to be racist in any way and no one
felt he was racist in any way well
that's worth it when you want when you
reaiiy think Cosell was just shy being
an ACLU lawyer I used to read Cosell and
Sport magazine once a month and he was
always at the vanguard of these
movements who was tighter with that
league for God's sakes and you know I
saw a special on that leave the other
night it was called I am Ali and I was
reminded I did not appreciate what he
did to Joe Frazier indeed he missed his
own he buried his own lead at some point
when he called Frazier names and stuff
like that and they had Marvis Frazier
I'm talking about I heard his father and
hurt his family so he wasn't perfect
Dada but I watched a guy operate between
races so seamlessly and that thing I
thought there's what we should all be
striving to get to not being complete if
it was so beautiful he was
proud of being black and beautiful and
then he'd be with these old square white
people teasing with a happy with the
grannies then he'd be with the children
and I thought now here's a guy who gets
it gets the human condition but we're
nowhere near that it's so uptight now
it's crazy this is total offshoot but
the reference is is your brain just
designed that way well you listen I I
realized my liabilities and I would say
one thing that I would say I'm okay at
as I have a reasonably deep cultural
drawer and a somewhat quick retrieval
system when I see those Christmas
stories every or where the kids are
working in the Amazon disbursements
centers and minute all or something and
they got packages coming at butts people
you asked me what I wanted to do for at
the Y in the road and said okay Emery
boards headphones
boom boom boom I think I could have been
the what do they call it on the kitchen
shows I could think I could have worked
the pass on cultural referencing yeah
but you see you just but that was just
natural to you that it was just sort of
all there was that saying that you were
going forward and you were like oh
that'll be my stick well I think it was
a it's a bit of a monkey tricks I don't
I don't know where you get that nor do I
think it's anything that you say where
you get that yeah but I do remember on
Saturday Night Live when I would get to
write the news and after a few weeks
they had so many holes in the dike they
let me kind of be in herb Sargent we're
right in the news other people would
write jokes but it we predominantly
wrote it and I noticed you have to get
actual about yourself I couldn't I
needed adrenaline to be really creative
and adrenalin came from fear for me so I
would notice
I could not occasionally a joke would
pop into my head Monday through Thursday
but I could see life on the griddle is
what perked me so Friday around 4:30 in
the afternoon it was really funny I'd
think about Whitney Brown and he was so
smart a little more the level of me but
a brilliant cat and we were kind of
friends but kinda I always thought if we
go to a to two anchors thing it's witty
so 4:30 in the afternoon on Friday and
take a Whitney and I think brother you
better get this thing together you
better quit this I can't write
you do three bad ones of these in a row
you either out or your co-host yeah and
that's one thing I'm proud I've made it
six years of never co-hosted yeah so at
4:30 yeah they all are right for years
now I I think I don't know I did it
alone but I always look back on that and
think well that was a good thing but
when you were served your opportunity
you stepped up to it but I remember I
had a big three big sheets of paper long
but that size on my wall three different
ones and it would say indignation and
then the middle one said what am i and
then the third one said arcane reference
and it was okay it was like a haiku for
update yeah I get to a point where I'd
think oh what some would do and I just
look at that and go what pisses you off
put the seesaw in the fulcrum what am i
yeah you know the jetsons robot me you
know I used to like make it reductive
reductio ad absurdum I really got primal
at that point I felt like I was like you
know like you're a great white yeah you
might as well heard the theme from the
jaws is you just swim and looking for
the line yeah as I I got scared that I
would lose the game but I did have that
template in my head so maybe that's
where the reference yeah and now it just
seems like it's just sort of built in or
something like it just well I must say
that uh even before I became a comedian
goofy stuff would stick in my I don't
know yeah but I remember watching one of
your eight how many HBO specials I'd be
good well I've got a nine one-hour
specials eight of them work so I'm
thinking it must have been one eight one
of your first ones I remember watching
again I'm young I'm 15 something like
that thinking I don't get all of this
but I like it you know you mean like
there were things that you were saying
that I was like I don't know what that
reference is but I kind of liked it
because I was like other people are
laughing so there must be something here
that's not the Water Commission bro yeah
you know it's somehow the rhythms of it
or in toxic yeah yeah I just remember
thinking lean into this you're if you're
gonna rat-a-tat-tat you're working that
speed bag you can't miss it I got the
words down I delivered them and I
remember thinking if they don't get the
actual content of this do the d'Artagnan
thing
lura SH you know yeah you don't have to
prick the other guy's chest plate but
he's gonna stand out there and have the
blade twang and I was always making sure
the right one oh god that's so funny to
meet it now I'd like to go back and
watch some of them now and sort of yeah
yeah and I always know it was a bit of a
scam yeah listen i-i've my boards like
10 20 I'm not but I I did have like I
said I could remember things and get to
them quickly and then I was smart enough
to think you can half-ass this sheepish
is the death of this you've got to lean
into it and then I used to always love
Carson's moves when he yeah yeah yeah
Johnny's blue one or it wasn't there I
used to find that intoxicating look
debonair just a little head movement a
little I I used to sit at home I didn't
even know what showbiz was it I think
now there's a cool cat it's in it's in
the the moments where you need to escape
the bad one so I always that was another
thing I did on Weekend Update I always
remember things some of these are dogs
when it dies a dog's death you've got to
be alert enough to say that in front of
people they'll find that intoxicating
yeah like you got to look up and say no
I'm not so needy that my self-esteem is
in your hands right now but I to know
that was a bad yeah but a lot of guys
since you have fallen into that trap
what do you mean tell me what I'm
looking for applause yeah yeah when they
know it's not working where you would
shake it I mean you would lure you just
did it but you would sort of shake it
off kind of where they're kind of like
ah please well it's just just the nature
I don't watch enough young guy there's a
few cats i watch yeah I think Maniscalco
is like a stone killer
I love his rhythms and Brian's a Gregory
it's a great comedian but I don't watch
enough of the young guys I do know that
at some point comedy almost turned into
what Impressionists used to get where
you get applause that was feel like
instead of you going Al Pacino working
in a Burger King I think it would go
something like this I feel like guys are
doing that with their political opinions
now oh yeah I think and then they
present it and you know here
buddy laughing he's just here this and I
was never into that yeah so even though
I can sense that Dennis Miller 2020 is
slightly evolved out of maybe the full
grind and fight thing
where are you sort of at politically I
asked you right before we started and
it's like you strike me as you're
probably absolutely yeah you strike me
as mostly libertarian kind of something
like that come in I meet your husband
yeah I can't believe there are people in
the world who don't see people in love
yeah and just be happy for I see the
picture of all these you bet I don't
want to talk about you can a beautiful
big family Walton Mountain shot
everybody's smiling
you two guys are at the center of it I
don't know if it's your wedding day or
whatever the wedding day and I'm
thinking how do you get to the point in
life where you're going up to strangers
and say here's what I think about you
know there's that so that part of lip or
conservativism and I'm not putting that
I know there's some Christian people who
think they go to hell if they sanction
I'm not gonna get dumb not their shrink
I can't get into their life and figure
all that out I just know I'm a believer
and I've never had a chat with my god
but sexuality it's just never came up it
never came up and I've met enough
fervent believers who are homosexual
they what does God say I can't talk to
you today you're gay so that whole thing
doesn't exist for me yeah I don't trust
radical Islam as far as I can throw it
I'd like to keep half my money some
people think that's a piggish statement
but they always think really bastard
yeah but I think people say you know and
after I pay taxes on I'd like to keep it
for my kids and then they go why do you
want to spoil your kids with a you know
inheritance and I go because I don't
even know your kids yeah at least like a
joy out of my kids it's pretty simple
stuff I feel like I'm a pragmatist but
in today's world man if you're not in
lockstep you're paint it is Christ I've
seen pictures of myself with a Hitler's
- yeah and I think I can't spend time
worrying about that those people are so
reactionary that the only thing the only
way I can let them into my life as if I
let them ding me mmm I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm more than willing to seek the
probation Strangers it's the human
condition but only if it's worth it
and I get I get a pretty good spidey
sense I can tell early on do I do I even
need to know this person anymore
you know you meet some people within
five minutes you go too strident I'm
still willing to make these calls for
myself sorry I'm in my own control tower
I gotta get I can't accept every plane
that once the shirt on the deck I got a
pic and I can tell pretty quickly
and if somebody's amenable just to be
open mind I don't even need to agree
with them on politics any of that [ __ ]
are they kind enough or they a decent
enough soul a good family person that's
a big thing with me funny they make me
laugh so I got my criteria
one of them's not being dovetailed with
their political beliefs but I see one
side of it I see it as the left I don't
even know I think you're making some
journey or something I've always heard
you're liberal and maybe if I would man
I think I'm an old-school liberal I
think that's basically what you are
you're in you believe solution should be
free and well even even on the economic
stuff an old-school liberal didn't want
high taxes you will you actually wanted
low taxes you wanna sell Finity we need
to cry to you
JFK yeah knots the top rate down from 78
of high 30s imagine Bernie Sanders
waiting in there this country could but
is that crazy - you have some really bad
ideas has I started to become seemingly
normal now anytime you see kids looking
up at Bernie Sanders in the same way you
see those young girls at the Sullivan
Show looking at the Beatles the world's
gone horribly askew uh see those kids
and I think are you kidding me this is
the guy we used to avoid his lawn
because nobody knew if he had buckshot
loaded up all of a sudden he's he's
suitable it it makes me laugh Bernie
Sanders can't believe he's pulled it off
what do you think the obsession with
politics is like that kind of thing
you're right that's yeah you think
that's that's it more listen and when
you get to a point and for kids I know
they're going to talk about health care
but I by and large I don't think kids in
their 20s they're always so invincible
our thinking and I'm gonna have a goiter
when I'm 70 is it going to be
covered I don't think they work that way
I do think a lot of kids are getting out
of college now with the north of a
hundred or hi tens school loan they
can't even get off the pad in their 80s
it's almost like they're working with
loan sharks yeah they gotta pay that off
before they can get to their dreams
therefore they think [ __ ] my dreams I'm
not gonna have in a house I'm gonna live
in a small micro apartment I'm not gonna
get a car I'm gonna bike around or pick
up one of these jerk-off scooters on
every corner and I'm gonna go out once a
week with my friends and film the
Michelob commercial we're all sitting
around we're all putting our beer on top
of the turntable and I'm gonna pay for a
great glass of wine because I don't have
any options on getting a house or a car
and I think all that's happened is if I
was a kid and I was sitting there with a
hundred grand worth of school loans and
it was for an environmental studies
degree or Kraig frankly I went out and
they said here's some here's some
dishwashing solution go clean that dove
up on the beach
I'd be saying who's the guy wants to
forgive my love I'd probably be gone
back but I'm not anymore I'm an old guy
who had minimal school loans paid them
off and they can't expect me to go back
and see it that way
I don't want to give up everything for
people who if I was telling a kid right
now I'd say the brother and listen
brother sister unless there's a super
serious thing you can get a degree in
that you can exchange for your green
rectangles
don't go yeah because all these Pete
half the people going in right now are
getting degrees that mean nothing and
you could have four years on the ground
find out what you want get in there get
into whatever the equivalent of the
mailroom is spend those four years you
know Jesus for God's sakes about 1,500
days while they're sitting in there you
know I got holding seances and stuff
like this where you can be out there
building a resume where the boss goes
that kid busts his ass so when the
college kid gets out and comes in yo
I've got a degree I was in student
government and the guy has to pretend
well that's right it is one end up in a
lawsuit he's thinking I got this kid
busting his ass for four years I'm gonna
give him the gig so I think politics
young people come down to school loans
what do you think of the other guy we've
spoke for 40 minutes well I haven't said
that no the T words oh we can do buy it
and let's do buy to where yeah we Biden
we didn't talk about Trump yet it's been
40 minutes luckily well yeah let's do
let's do Biden listen I I've always made
fun of I you know I I think he's anybody
who gets in at 29 and is now 77 is
inviting guys like me to make fun of oh
yeah I know he's helping me Joe you know
I don't need you know is he helping you
out of the open he always talks about
how I've been in public service oh okay
yeah thanks for helping but you know III
don't dig guys who get off who quite
frankly get off their old man's nickel
on to the public time and their late 20s
ride it all the way and it always bored
me with Jerry Brown you know he's
pitching himself as you know an ethereal
creature and I always think brother
you've been on the teat for like four or
six decade now okay so don't tell me
about what a free form you are but Biden
has never been as smart as they told me
it was her he told you he was anybody
who knows their IQs a big tell for me
two things when a guy you're golfing
with goes into the woods and you get to
the green you go what you get and he
pulls his hand up I know he's [ __ ]
and whatever guy says I know my IQ I go
Christ I I don't like that to begin with
I go why why do you know your IQ that
insecure you faking it that much
fighting is one of those guys who knows
his own IQ and I never saw him as a
genius I always think of Joe Biden is
the third guy in a car on a sonic
commercial you know just popping up and
I love the tater tots - so he's no
genius and but now he looks addled oh
yeah whoa yeah what do you think of that
I mean it does it something is seriously
wrong I'm sort of subdural haematoma
years ago right yeah but it's only in
the last he had that something like 20
years examinees office feed they're
gonna push him ahead you might get
elected I'll tell you what he'll never
go on a debate stage with Trump he'll
never do that in and I can hear the
whole thing they'll put it on prompter
for him ago I would not normalize this
man by being on the same stage with him
it would be beneath my dignity but more
importantly more in
we beneath the dignity of the American
people and it will get all tied up and
poignant Lee and end up you know in a
straitjacket they won't even know
they'll have to come out and get him
offstage but they'd vote him in because
they hate Trump that much I think he's
by the board's I don't think he was all
that much to begin with
I don't like back slappers I don't like
glad handers I don't like that core
[ __ ] about I I walked through the
diner today and he find out the diner
hasn't been there in 20 years you know i
Biden just never impressed me to me he's
always been more unhinge than a rescue
dog and Phil Spector's house where we
get the the Trump guy do you think a
good person like actually like sort of
an enlightened decent human being could
ever be part of this thing it seems like
the ship has pretty much sailed on that
although I think a great reckoning could
be coming maybe to our whole political
there so cataclysmic it remains to me
unimaginable ya know I think it is
automatic yeah I don't know if it'll be
29 where all of a sudden the Dow you
know it's happening now because of the
virus but I'm just saying it'll either
be 1929 or 1860 something like that the
unimaginable you don't want to be the
first guy in Section C a civil war
coming they'll make you out to be the
bad yeah it seriously for the reset that
happened I don't see it being
incremental I see something just the shy
of cataclysmic happening maybe Corona is
it I don't know but if anybody thinks
the Dems are gonna solve Corona after
what I just saw in their own caucus is
in Iowa I don't know that I want to hand
it off to them but I don't see it coming
back around I see it getting very tribal
and I can only hope at some point we
divvy up the albums like the
relationship that's gone it's like Woody
Allen in Annie Hall we got a dead shark
here nobody uses it yeah and what we got
here is a dead shark and give me the
album's up so what does that mean though
what does that actually mean like what
does that look like we divvy up the
albums what meaning what we're in we
should split up in my mind I don't see
it coming back around I don't know how
to do that that doesn't work out very
well for guys like me and you in
California you know you move I don't
even know if it's Geographic I don't
know what I'm saying you know people
exactly I'm telling you I think at this
point
we got a dead shark and I don't quite
know how we figure it out but at some
point we shouldn't try to go closer
together cuz that's only gonna make it
more rancorous we don't get along we
don't even agree I I tell you one thing
I do notice is I find people I've been
on the right and I've been on the left
as far as issues in my life I've also
been thought of as somebody's on the
left and on the right mistakenly over my
life I find the left is really more
brutal than the right I mean I used to
tear people in the conservative
community a new [ __ ] when I'd meet
him that kind of nice laugh about it
yeah and the left man it dangerous you
know you want to catch a d-cell on a
tube sock if you don't agree and so
that's why I zip it periodically were
you kind of shocked though when you
first started seeing that like you first
go on O'Reilly maybe happened then I
wasn't Mort Sahl wrote a great book
years ago called Heartland and I think
when people think back on Mort saw they
always think of him as liberal probably
because he was Sancho Panza or Boswell
to Kennedys Jack what am I thinking
pause well Sam Johnson to kennedy sam
johnson he was a chronicler and he liked
being in the with the cool kids but he
started to see it and he started talking
about liberalism and he was a real
hipster boy I don't even know more it's
still up there maybe he's passed but no
no he's still alive unless something
happened last week I'm 99% he just
started having that epiphany I remember
it happened with Stockdale
I remember everybody's making fun of
Stockdale and I think McCain had told me
once the stock tale when he was in the
Hanoi Hilton
when kids given up and they were gonna
kill themselves he would get on the pipe
at night and tap it with a flint to pray
with them in sign language to convince
them not to die that night
Wow like something that maybe what a
thousand men in the history of planet
have been consequential enough to do and
then he's on cable when he goes I don't
even know why I learned everybody makes
him an [ __ ] and I thought this room's
got too hip for me if we're gonna start
like talking about
Stockdale like he's an idiot and Nancy
Pelosi is a viable player I just thought
I can't be in the live today they asked
too much of the lockstep yeah you think
the Republicans have any
sort of more functional people I find
that but I can only speak for myself
like I said I've poked a lot of fun of
concern yeah and I've met some who hated
my guts that I've met others who at
least laughed about it a little that's
just my experience people on the left
does not take a joke as well I think
that's kind of I don't think I'm saying
anything
sacrilegious there I think a lot of
people were noticing that guess what
nobody wants to say I hear you Miller
yeah in my life you don't want to end up
in the crosshairs of that gets ugly man
so what do you think of that Trump guy
well listen I'll say this about Donald
Trump
I think his outer voice as crazy as it
can be is an entirely accurate depiction
of his inner voice whereas I don't think
somebody like Hillary Clinton's inner
voice and outer voice have ever even had
a cup of coffee together listen there
are days I look at Trump and I'm
mortified I think God can't it just shut
up but I don't spend every day of my
life because it's just this tedious day
I wish you'd quit tweeting I hear people
that's their that's what they wake up in
the morning what they they're not gonna
quit tweeting he doesn't drink so you
know lighten up [ __ ] is his cognac
before bed that's what he does but do I
think he's done some good things yeah I
do do I think he's done some things that
aren't panning out now the kids firing
missiles again in North Korea I don't
know he might have to smoke him at some
point but I do I think meeting with him
is a bad idea no I don't do I see Obama
what he's in there having a leaning in
and saying tell tell Vladimir I'll have
more leeway to talk to my this all goes
on we should be talking it's just that
Obama never got outed for it they even
at the tape of them it's like DeLorean
selling blow in the room and he saw how
good sign the guys are taped Joe Biden's
on tape doing our thing they accused
trouble I can't do it anymore it's silly
do I think Donald Trump's pervy no he's
a boorish cat I like the way his kids
aren't they seem loyal and they seem to
be raised to be somewhat disciplined
they're days he goes after people or
anything brother that is so thin and I
can't believe it
are there other days I think Wow good
for you when I see a union guy in the
Oval Office with a hard hat on crying
because his old man came here from
Ireland and he would be proud beautiful
stuff I'm not going to play the game
where I think he's Hitler you know to me
that when they do that Hitler thing I
always say well what do you mean he's
Hitler and
he's gonna fear he's gonna croak six
million of his fellow humans and they
always say no of course I don't mean
that act like you're an [ __ ] what
other
Hitler peccadillo what you're talking
about the bad - bad artists reviews for
house painting what are you talking
about ah yeah I think well I think
you're basically right I mean they say
these things about him but is there a
piece of him that strikes you as very
much like he has the mind of a comic
because I saw his good timing I saw him
live in December and he goes up there
and you know he's got the prompter but
he's also winging it half the time and
he's ad libbing and everything and he
did this thing about he was talking
about windmills and he goes he goes I've
been studying windmills my whole life
nobody knows more about windmills than
me and then he starts you know give him
rifling off some stats about windmills
that were obviously on the prompter and
I turned to David and I was like you
know that the headline in Politico today
is gonna be Donald Trump says he knows
more about windmills than anyone which
he obviously meant as a joke and then lo
and behold we see all the headlines
BuzzFeed bla bla bla and it's like I
think that's his greatest gift he knows
how to Punk these guys every time
whether you like it or not but that's
the I can't even do that with him
anymore
everybody talks about Trump now notice
how many times the word whether you like
him or not comes out that's all a
sleighing covering fire done don't like
him some days but it's about more
trivial [ __ ] than some of the stuff he's
doing which matters I think some of the
things he's doing as far as the you know
when somebody comes to me and say say
says that the black unemployment rates
down to its lowest ever and and somebody
immediately goes Obama's sorry baby okay
I'll give Obama credit for that I'm
gonna give him credit for getting it
down a little lower I just can't play
this stupid game where he's the
Antichrist
for God's sakes there are days I feel
that he's a super adept at his job
there are other times I think he's super
thin skin there are days I think he's
about his comedy chops are you know
beautiful yeah there are other days I
find it buffoonish that he would waste
time punching down to somebody that's
the other stupid on the other side he's
the human condition to me all I know is
this I don't see the country being over
as they do I don't this corner virus is
yet another thing they're going to say
the
trees over I guess I'm a half full guy
so I think they were occasionally do I
see Trump is half full of it or half
empty
yeah I guess I do there are other days I
look up and say good for you I wouldn't
take this [ __ ] either
imagine the the mouse term this guy is
and on a day-to-day basis him and his
wife and when people say we'll use
meaning to tweet I go yeah and he's
punching back what do you think by the
way we just go from that crisis to cry
while I'm doing it yeah you just yeah I
need a I'm gonna ask for a week off
between vaping a billion creatures
killed in Australia and coronavirus net
neutrality killed half the people I know
it's too hysterical i I don't want to
live that way and if people find that
harsh I don't I don't know what to say I
do know this I saw the coronavirus
figure for today and people's oh you're
so simple-minded it's obviously ten
times more I guess I am stupid when they
when I read an article that says we've
lost you had 10,000 people this flu
season and we've lost 34 coronavirus and
then the end of that article is an
expert saying thus the corona virus is
10 times more lethal than the flu I go
okay get some too stupid to follow that
it's like when they used to have the
unemployment rate would go when less
people when more people were employed
and it would go up you know what I mean
then they'd say well there are less
people there are less people there where
it's at yeah more people have selected
out of the workforce know where they're
willing to concede I'm not as smart as
somebody like yeah I just thought they'd
figure it out I don't wait more than who
they are
I see her quoted I think okay I wish I
could keep up I used to love her well
yeah but she's a cold day no I'm sure
she it's just that I guarantee you Joyce
hippin off the one she gets the left to
her own devices
she can't achieve and she's been used
that she's treated like she's speaking
in encyclical yeah she's a great comic
and she's fine a great gig and I know
she's liberal but I'm just saying the
the the what I see people now is being
the source material
I just like sort of laugh I'm more than
willing to concede on a rant let me say
60% of the world issues I'm guessing
like most people are and the other 40
seems set in stone they just seem you
don't put 15 billion on a pallet and fly
it let's see if you can't see that
you're missing the point so bad move
you're saying yeah at least give them a
check and in the memo section to
liquidate is real yeah alright but
instead we do - no here go use this what
are you guys gonna do you Andy you're
canning this season trust us trust this
first what else is kind of interesting
to you these days let me see what have I
been doing well as I said I'm trying to
read a lot and I'm reading voraciously
and I hike I go walking at almost three
times a week with my friend Jimmy
Connors the tennis oh wow and he's a bit
of a pisser and he lives near me I saw
him on a plane about a year ago we were
waiting to get on I went up to him and I
mentioned you know that crazy year what
was it like 94 102 and three yeah he
kind of smiled at me any nod no it's
like I was just that guy that I
mentioned that one thing well let me
tell you this everybody talks about
Federer and he's obviously I think even
Jimmy would probably say the greatest
player ever because of the the majors
but to this day in the open tennis
tournament Roger Federer is around 30
matches wins behind Jimmy who's in the
one slot and he's around six tournaments
behind Jimmy and Jimmy never beats that
drum ban and when I go I go I'll go
Jimmy why do you ever tell me this I
looked it up and he'll gaff like that
you know and he'll right away start
talking about other things so I joined
that that guy played with I mean the
Elan I know there's a fine line there
and Jimmy was never happy time out there
is a stone killer and guess what in a
world of tepid in a world where
everybody's figuring out how to explain
somebody's missteps before you get to
them to have a guy who's an honest
arbiter of his legacy tells you where he
screwed up where he tells me at least
tells me where he did well and let the
numbers speak and doesn't beat the drum
he's a mensch you know I like that
about people and there's too many too
many altruistic people with publicists
nowadays imagine the selflessness being
shepherded down a red carpet bike you
know rogers & Cowan hey this guy did
something that nobody's supposed to know
about can we get a team over here
I don't think here's the wing he just
named after him I feel like we're there
alright better I feel like I got like a
full-on thing from you I wasn't exactly
sure I got a little bit of a different
thing than I was expecting actually it's
kind of cool well you're pretty easy man
thanks for let me talk and I'm glad
you're doing so well
I'm glad you're happy man things alright
never read the great Tom Wolfe book well
I like that I don't know if a lot of
people called a man in full it was a
book well you'd have to read it it's
about a man reaches a point in his life
where if he feels he's a man in full
indeed he very well could be and that's
not defined as you classically defined
on your kid it just has to come a moment
where you just sit there and there's no
static and you just say it's not even
exultant it's not triumphant it's just
kind of quiet and you think wow I feel
like a man in full right now the the
private jet and my head's letting down a
little you know what I've never read the
book but I do love Frank Sinatra's my
way and I think that's kind of I think
oh the Frank didn't think the song is
that right you know Paul Anka wrote it
yeah and Frank wasn't his cup of tea
this is when you're the chairman you
don't want to have to be you know
regrets I've I don't know the Frank
except you're selling millions of copies
I don't know that Frank's gonna go out
and introspect in front of strangers
yeah but I ever tell you my Sinatra
story no tell me your Sinatra story and
this was Sinatra okay this is a cool
story I'm in Vegas one night Tom dreesen
calls me the great Chicago yeah he's
open for Sinatra down at the Desert Inn
which isn't even there anymore that's
how long ago this was I'm up at the MGM
Grand he says listen I'm will open up
for Frank tonight and you want to come
down and see the show and I go yeah yeah
I said what if we're working at the same
time sir I checked we're off set come
down after your show I go down to see
Sinatra Driessen says I'll leave me as
many tickets as you want now I'm in town
with my wife was pregnant with our
second child
and our baby our Filipino nanny Khoikhoi
and my mum's with me and me I do the
show I go back to collect and my wife
says you know I don't I don't want to go
I don't feel up to it I feel sick and
I'm gonna stay in and I go I got three
tickets why don't I take quickly because
I hear her in a room at night listen
it's not joints well she's a great idea
off we go
nanny my mom and I would go down to see
Sinatra he you know it's like it's a
revelation for me and he's not on top of
his game he's a bit in his day no mom
but it's still fatty Sinatra Frank yeah
I'm thinking yeah I'm knee-deep in it I
go back to thank Driessen after the show
and I he says unbelievable he says hey
Frank Doug you on SNL you want to have
dinner we go to that old restaurant in
the Desert Inn it was an Italian place
and had a gold cheap gold elevator
circular you'd go up and you'd go in and
there'd be the bar and then the main
room and then the VIP room then the VVIP
room then the pope room and weigh in the
colonel in the nucleus the Sinatra roof
we'd go all the way back trees and opens
the door there's a table it's pretty
small there's like ten people and there
sits a notch right across from a barber
his wife sits here his attorney is here
as attorneys wife over his shoulder too
huge Luca Brasi Driessen sits here and
my mom sits here I sit across from
Sinatra Khoikhoi The Nanny sitting here
and around ten minutes in I realized
they're being so nice to us they think
quite close my wife and I don't want to
shut it down say no no it's mine I
figure I'll just roll with this so I
started getting shit-faced I'm not a big
drinker but I'm thinking I'm with
Sinatra I'm putting something on cubes
and I'm gonna tinkle the glass just
talking about a fight he had at mr.
Kelly's in Chicago I'm thinking Christ
up in Ocean's eleven this is the
greatest thing so I toss it and then
we're having fun and then quite coy
nudges me under the table I look done
she's got an autograph book on her way
laughs and she she's motioning and I I
can't say anything so I have to go
complete body language Lee I look up and
I'm locked eyes with Sinatra he's
looking and thinks I'm having a
grandmother freak so I have to flat not
go tabla Ross and so I'm just sitting
there but now it's hanging over my head
the autograph look at Damocles so around
an hour and I got think we got a blow
cuz I'm too nervous now go around the
table now here's how cool Frank as my
mum goes up first she said mr. Sinatra
when I was a young girl 1950s - I saw
you at the Stan Lee Theatre in
Pittsburgh and have dinner with you is
the biggest thrill of my life so Dajjal
exam eases 52 Stan Lee Theatre in
Pittsburgh I remember that show baby you
were on the left side of the stage you
look good that like a ferngully fairy
I'm all choked up I step in I go Frank
yes what you just did for my mother he
gives me the Jilly Rizzo face levy he'd
get out of here I turned quickly steps
left lap she hits it with the autograph
look I almost pass out I got that cold
sweat and I hear Sinatra over my
shoulder say did you say soy soy and the
bodyguard says Khoikhoi Frank quite coy
and Sinatra actually says okay see what
I can't even listen they come out
they're flying in tandem like the Blue
Angels now I can't get mad at her she
just came from another world dinner with
Sinatra she's in shock
I go geez quick well let me see it I
open up to the page II sign it says to
soap oh it's like he went so far but I
said [ __ ] I'm trying here here's your
Sinatra name that's like and you called
her soap Oh from that well later on I
went up when she got married to her golf
club and we were and people were coming
up and going so you know soap up so this
story lived on floor and she was the
sweetest soul Miller it's been an
absolute pleasure
oh you walk it out in the middle I'm
going to take a bye over here oh sorry
I've been talking for like four hours
yeah oh my god it was a lot of talking
follow this guy at Dennis DMZ on Twitter
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about comedy
instead of the nonstop yelling you get
everywhere else check out our comedy
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlists they're
both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell